now we head to the southern border surge
the president's homeland security chief
was at the u.s mexico border today
a trip that included no press access
no news conference continuing a media
blackout about what's
happening happening inside those
facilities on the border
correspondent griff jenkins is down
there he's live tonight in sunland park
new mexico good evening griff
good evening brad and a blackout still
continues we are still unable
to go on ride-alongs to see inside
facilities or interview
border patrol officials but last night
we witnessed more than 25 apprehensions
spoke with some of the migrants and we
spoke to senator rob portman
who is with the dh secretary today
homeland security secretary alejandro
mayorkas visiting the southern border
for the first time
a visit on the heels of intense scrutiny
over the administration's handling
of the crisis but the message from the
administration remains
i can say quite clearly don't come
migrants say that message
won't make a difference do you think
more will come
under the new administration
ohio senator rob portman says it's
because
migrants are hearing a different message
what they're
hearing from the new administration is
you know we're going to stop
deportations for 100 days
you know we're going to stop the
remaining mexico program portman
received a tour
of the el paso sector from the border
patrol union
we were able to ride along we saw quite
a lot of action tonight actually
what did you take away well griff i saw
tonight what's happening all over this
border which is there are more people
coming art del cueto vice president of
the national border patrol council
hopes portman will convince congress for
more help
what do you want him to take back to
washington no obviously
how undermanned the agents are out here
they're putting their lives on the line
each and every day
and we need more personnel
some feel the biden administration is
doing enough i think the administration
is pulling this thing under control
others say
the situation is far from under control
it's a total disaster texas governor
greg abbott
is calling out the administration for
its handling of the crisis
in the middle of a pandemic there is no
viable usable running water
at the location in midland and then on
top of that
more than 10 percent of the migrants at
the midland location
have now tested positive per cova 19.
back at the border
migrants face their own set of risks to
travel here
but for many the risks are worth taking
look if you guys lived in the in our
country
you guys will know that it's really
tough it's really tough
we did not hear from the secretary
publicly after his visit here
to see the facility housing children
which hit capacity
this week the number of unaccompanied
miners crossing the border here in this
sector
is up more than 140 percent brett
griff jenkins along the border in new
mexico griff thank you